>> Jeanine: THE DEMOCRATS
PROVING AGAIN HOW TOTALLY INEPT
AND CLUELESS THEY THEY ARE ON
THE ISSUES.
KAMALA HARRIS WAS ASKED POINT
BLANK ABOUT SOARING INFLATION.
THE VEEP OFFERING UP THIS MESS
OF AN ANSWER.
>> NOW INFLATION IS REALLY HIGH.
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT A
RECESSION?
THE ADMINISTRATION SAID THAT
THEY WEREN'T THAT WORRIED ABOUT
INFLATION AND THEN THAT CHANGED.
>> I THINK THAT THERE CAN BE NO
HIGHER PRIORITY THAN WHAT WE
HAVE BEEN CLEAR IS OUR HIGHEST
PRIORITY, WHICH IS BRINGING DOWN
THE COSTS AND THE PRICES AS MUCH
AS WE POSSIBLY CAN.
WE WILL STAY FOCUSED ON THAT.
>> Dana:
>> Jeanine: THAT COMES AS A NEW
REPORT INDICATES JOE BIDEN IS
GETTING IRRITATED BY DEMOCRATS
THAT WILL NOT OPENLY BACK HIM TO
RUN FOR RE-ELECTION.
OKAY, SHALL I START WITH THE
WORD SALAD?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Geraldo: I'M REALLY APPALLED
BY HER INABILITY TO PUT TOGETHER
THOUGHTFUL MESSAGES EVEN WHEN
GIVEN A SOFTBALL QUESTION.
I REALLY TRY TO BE A FAN OF
HERS.
I RECOGNIZE HER HISTORIC
IMPORTANCE.
BUT I HAVE TO SAY THIS.
THE ISSUE IS WHETHER OR NOT
REPUBLICANS CAN KEEP PEOPLE
INTERESTED IN THEIR INCOMPETENCE
ON IMMIGRATION, ON THE ECONOMY,
ON INFLATION ON THE BORDER AND
SO FORTH OR WILL THE DEMOCRATS
WIN OUT IN THE END DESPITE ALL
OF THIS MIXED MESSAGING AND
MISSED MESSAGING BY ALLOWING THE
VOTERS TO FOCUS ON THE ABORTION
RULING AND ON JANUARY 6th.
THE HEARINGS TODAY APPALLING IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEY REVEAL.
SO IT'S REALLY WHO GETS THE
MESSAGE PIÑATA AND SHE'S NOT
HELPING THE DEMOCRATS.
>> Kat: NO.
THE WORD SALAD IS NONSTOP.
THERE'S PEOPLE THAT ARE ACTUALLY
SUFFERING.
THEY WANT TO KNOW WHAT IS GOING
TO HAPPEN.
THAT DOES NOT INSPIRE
CONFIDENCE.
I HEAR SOMEBODY LIKE THAT -- I
CAN ORDER THEM AN UBER AND HAVE
THEM THROW UP IN IT.
PEOPLE ARE REALLY STRUGGLING.
THEY'VE BEEN TOLD THAT GAS WILL
GET BETTER.
IT'S NOT GOING TO GET BETTER.
IT'S GETTING WORSE.
PEOPLE AREN'T GOING TO FORGET
ABOUT IT BECAUSE THEY'RE FACING
IT EVERY DAY.
>> Jeanine: DANA, WHEN SHE WAS
ASKED WHAT BIDEN HAD DONE TO
LOWTER PRICE OF GAS BESIDES THE
GAS TAX HOLIDAY, SHE DIDN'T HAVE
AN ANSWER.
>> Dana: IT'S AMAZING THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE A READY ANSWER.
IT WAS LIKE A COUPLE WEEKS AGO,
THE NEW PRESS SECRETARY ASKED
ABOUT THE BABY FORMULA CRISIS.
SHE SAID I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
ON THAT.
THOSE ARE THINGS YOU HAVE TO
HAVE IN YOUR BACK POCKET.
I DO BELIEVE THAT INFLATION IS
THE BIGGEST PROBLEM.
IT'S NOT THE HIGHEST PRIORITY.
THAT'S OBVIOUS.
THE DEMOCRATS THEMSELVES ARE
SAYING THAT.
YOU HAD AN ANONYMOUS DEMOCRAT
QUOTED IN A CNN PIECE THIS WEEK
SAYING THEY VACILLATE BETWEEN
NOT HAVING A PLAN OR BLAMING
SOMEBODY ELSE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE WAITING LIKE
WHICH WAY ARE WE GOING, BOSS?
GERALDO IS RIGHT.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE HOPING TO HIDE
THEIR ECONOMIC FAILURES BY
FOCUSING ON SOMETHING LIKE ROE
V. WADE.
REPUBLICANS ARE SAYING THERE'S
ROE V. WADE, BUT THEY NEED TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DEAL WITH THAT
COMMUNICATION AS WELL.
THEY'RE PLANNING TO RUN JUST ALL
ACROSS THE BOARD ON INFLATION.
YOU MIND IF I CALL FOR THIS
SOUND BITE?
THIS WAS SIGNIFICANT.
ABIGAIL SPAN BERGER IS IN A
SWING DISTRICT.
SHE'S SAYING THE SQUAD IS WRONG
A LONG TIME.
I ASKED HER IF SHE WOULD
CAMPAIGN WITH BIDEN.
THIS IS WHAT SHE SAID.
>> I INTEND TO DO THE
CAMPAIGNING MYSELF.
I'M THE CANDIDATE.
IT'S MY NAME ON THE BALLOT.
WHEN I RAN, I RAN IN AN R-SEVEN
DRIVEN AND I GOT OUT SPOKE TO
VOTERS AND WON MAKING SURE THEY
KNOW WHO I AM AND WHAT I
INTENDED TO DO FOR THEM.
>> Dana: YOU'LL SEE MORE OF
THAT.
REMEMBER WHEN STACEY ABRAMS HAD
A SCHEDULING CONFLICT?
THERE'S A LOT OF THAT.
>> Jeanine: JESSIE, IF 75% OF
AMERICANS SAY THE ECONOMY IS
BAD, THEY HAVE X NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WORRIED ABOUT ROE V.
WADE, I WONDER IF ROE V. WADE
WILL BE AS HEAVY ON THEIR MINDS
AS THE ECONOMY, AS IT CONTINUES
TO GET WORSE, GETTING CLOSER TO
NO.
>> Jesse: I THINK THE ECONOMY
TRUMPS ROE.
THE FAR LEFT WILL BE FIRED UP
ABOUT ROE.
IT'S OVERWHELMING THAT PEOPLE
ARE SUFFERING ECONOMICALLY AND
IT'S A TASTE THAT WON'T LEAVE
THEIR MOUTHS.
I'M JUST AS WORRIED THAT HARRIS
WILL TACKLE COSTS, NOT JUST THE
PRICES.
IS SHE SO BAD THAT YOU CAN SMELL
THE POLITICIAN THROUGH THE
SCREEN?
SHE'S ONLY GOOD AT MEMORIZATION.
I USED TO BE -- YOU CAN SEE HOW
SHE'S RECITING THINGS AS -- I
USED TO DO THIS.
I WAS HIRED AT 22 YEARS OLD TO
WORK IN AN ASSET MANAGEMENT
COMPANY AFTER COLLEGE.
I DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
ECONOMICS.
I COULD MEMORIZE AND I COULD
SPEAK.
WE WOULD GET UP AT THESE PITCH
MEETINGS WHERE I WOULD PRETEND
TO BE THE SALESMAN AND I'D GET
UP THERE RECITE BEAUTIFULLY WHAT
HOUR SALES PITCH WAS.
THE GUY RUNNING IT WOULD GO,
WATERS, WHAT IS A MORTGAGE
BACKED SECURITY?
I'D SAY IT'S A SECURITY BACKED
BY MORTGAGE?
HE G